Hay que factorizar
4y cuadrada más 4y menos 15.
Y bueno cuando tenemos algo al lado de la "y" cuadrada,
que en este caso es 4,
algo que no sea uno,
entonces pensamos
en factorización por agrupación.
En este video lo que voy a hacer
es factorizar esta expresión por agrupación
y bueno, para esto lo primero que hay que hacer
es buscar 2 números
que en su multiplicación me dé
la multiplicación de 4 por 15,
así que déjame ponerlo aquí,
"a" por "b" son dos números,
tales que su producto
me tiene que dar 4 por -15
es decir,
el primer el coeficiente por el último
y esto pues me da -60
y la suma de estos dos mismos números
me tienen que dar 4,
este 4 de aquí
y bueno, ya que tengo
estas 2 ecuaciones planteadas aquí,
lo que tengo que hacer
es resolverlas,
pensar en dos números
que su multiplicación me de - 60
y su suma me 4.
Y lo primero que quiero que veamos
es que este -60 es negativo
por lo tanto,
uno de éstos tienen que ser positivo
y el otro tiene que ser negativo,
y además me voy a buscar
dos números que no estén muy alejados
por que su diferencia me tiene que dar 4.
Voy a pensar primero en 5 y 12,
en 5 positivo y 12 negativo.
Cuando lo sumo obtengo el resultado -7
y si pongo al revés los signos
obtengo del resultado 7,
por lo tanto,
aunque 5 por 12 sea 60
estos no son los que quiero.
Vamos a fijarnos con 6 menos 10.
Estos dos me dan de suma -4
pero si el cambio de signo
me dan del resultado 4
que es justo lo que quiero.
-6 por 10 me da -60
mientras que por otra parte
-6 más 10 me da 4 positivo
por lo tanto,
lo que voy a hacer es poner estos dos aquí en medio,
es decir,
en lugar de poner 4y
lo voy a escribir como
-6y más 10y.
Entonces déjame ponerlo aquí,
este lo voy a poner como
-6y más 10y
porque date cuenta que menos 6y más 10y
es lo mismo que 4y.
Es justo para eso que me sirven
estos 2 valores que estaban buscando,
y bueno,
aquí me queda 4y cuadrada y al final me queda - 15,
date cuenta que puse
el 10y al lado del -15
porque me va a ser más fácil factorizar 10y en -15,
y por otra parte,
de 4y de cuadrada en -6y
porque en este momento es cuando empieza
la factorización por agrupación.
Factorización por agrupación
me refiero a
tomarme estos 2 primeros términos
que tengo aquí
y de aquí factorizar
lo más que se pueda,
de 4y cuadrada -6y,
lo más que se puede factorizar
es un 2y,
2y que a su vez
multiplica pues a 2y
y después a -3.
Si te das cuenta 2y por 2y
me da 4y cuadrada
y 2y por -3 me da -6y.
Bueno esta es la primera parte
de la factorización por agrupación,
lo que estamos haciendo es contar en grupos
toda esta expresión  para factorizarla.
Y ahora me voy a fijar en el segundo grupo,
me voy a tomar los siguientes dos términos
y de aquí voy a factorizar lo más que se pueda
y lo más que se puede de
10y menos 15 es un 5,
entonces 5 que va a multiplicar a,
y dice 10y entre 5,
es lo mismo que 2y
y -15 entre 5
es lo mismo que -3
y bueno,
lo padre de factorización por agrupación
es que si esta expresión
tiene factorización
entonces me van a quedar aquí,
un factor común,
mi factor común en este caso es 2y -3.
Date cuenta que tanto esta expresión,
como esta expresión tienen 2y menos 3 ,
por lo tanto,
voy a sacar este 2y menos 3
que en primer lugar va a multiplicar
a este 2y, a este de aquí, este 2y
y después va a multiplicar a este 5 que tengo acá,
y ya está.
La verdad es que
no hay mucha magia en esto,
al final lo único que estoy haciendo
es sacar este 2y menos 3
y ponerlo al principio
como si fuera mi factor común,
y después fijarme a quién está multiplicando
el 2y menos 3
y entonces me queda que la factorización
de 4y cuadrada más 4y menos 15
es 2y menos 3
que multiplica a 2y más 5.